ted was all over covering that heat wave
and really some big changes as you
talked about this week ted we've kind of
gone down the roller coaster it feels
good a little bit of rain too
excessive heat last week this week 84
degree temperature outside right now no
complaints here live look outside right
now
no showers coming down in the valley but
we have the clouds out there especially
over the mountains right now but we are
getting some clearing so are we done
with those showers
not just yet 92 our high for the day
today and get this
we hit that temperature at midnight 82
the low so far numbers are dropping
though so we switched the two we
inverted them
101 is our average for this time of year
so we are nearly 10 degrees below
average nowhere near that record of 113
degrees
currently outside 87 in sky canyon along
with satellite hills spring valley
82-87 for those of you in north las
vegas that includes downtown as well
nellis at double eights right now 87
whitney ranch
anthem at 87 along with southern
highlands 90 for henderson
and mountains edge at 82 with this hour
80 for sandy valley 90 for boulder city
the numbers here drop and
apologize we'll get those back up for
you 91 in mesquite 105 for death valley
at this hour radar network they're doing
their sweeps and they're picking up some
storms out there you see these icons
here near flagstaff
down your needles and out near barstow
those are thunderstorms and they're
drifting
to the north northeast so we'll wait and
see whether we get any of that however
that monsoon moisture will start to
scour out notice it starts to move its
way out of here by tomorrow
and beyond tomorrow keeping slight
chances still the forecast not as great
as today
but the possibility is still out there
for some parts of the region mainly to
the east and north of las vegas
or the mountains and then we start to
get to the late night hours for tomorrow
all that goes away and then we dry out
for friday here's your forecast 77
overnight
showers and thunderstorms will be
decreasing for this evening
we're looking for light winds light
breezes unless we get those storms that
will produce
those erratic winds 96 for tomorrow more
sunshine
slight thunderstorm chances for tomorrow
not as great as today like we talked
about
101 is where we should be so we have
another day of below average
temperatures
after today was 10 to 15 degrees cooler
than we were yesterday
95 for tomorrow for north las vegas
along with spring valley and desert
shores
93 for you in summerlin 94 centenni
hills 95 southern highlands
and 94 for henderson for tomorrow no
complaints at all 93 for prompt 94 for
boulder city 105 for lofton now remember
like we said
we should be at 101 for this time of the
year your eight
day forecast shows will be back to
normal friday
even hot as we get to the weekend next
week yes it will be hot with more clouds
but away from the extreme heat for next
week
that's your most accurate forecast
sashay